to take part in more polls about what
may be covered
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I found this what happened here
anything oh just this I found it this is
going on long enough this guy's been
gone for three weeks no calls no texts
no social media nothing
we need a new top five this week you two
think of something
oh no the scale tones behind you they do
really good work yes you dumb get to
work dumb what's that top five worst
Arnold Schwarzenegger performances
Walter must have written this before he
left
I'm Heather Ruth and I'm Ayanna weed and
this is top five we've covered his best
now let's get down to his worst the
Governator has had some pretty bad
performances that have followed him on
his long and successful career but which
ones scraped the bottom of the barrel
let's find out these are the top five
worst Arnold Schwarzenegger performances
number five Gunther in killing Gunther
this is Arnold's newest film and it's
really weird
Gunther the world's greatest hit man is
being hunted down by a group of
assassins who want him dead
their leader Blake has a personal
vendetta against him and hires a
documentary crew to follow his team
around so there's proof they killed the
best of the best
however Gunther always seems to be one
step ahead of them we have to say first
off props to SNL's taran killam for
writing directing and starring in this
it's obviously a passion project of his
and really cool that he even got to make
it happen getting Arnold involved in
this at all had to be a big deal for
Taryn but the way this film is
advertised
you'd think Schwarzenegger was in it a
substantial amount the truth is he's in
the movie for less than 20 minutes and
Arnold's performance here is not worth
the wait he's not absolutely terrible as
this self-absorbed instigator but he
does not fit in well with the over T
awkward tone of this movie they even
play at the scene where he's about to
sing a country song and they let an
impressionist sing it instead if you're
going to threaten us with Arnold singing
you better follow through don't worry it
gets worse from here number four
breacher in sabotage you ever want to
see a second-rate Expendables film but
way more disgusting an elite DEA task
force led by John breacher Wharton are
being taken out individually after they
steal money from a drug cartel
however there's much more to the story
than any of them are letting on and when
Detective Caroline Brentwood is assigned
to investigate the matter shocking
details start to come to light
breacher Grindr sugar pyro
tripod off-brand energy drinks or
characters in this movie you tell me
besides this film being unnecessarily
gross Google fuck dropped ass piss yeah
what you think I'm not gonna stick my
dick way yo dick been sticking it
alright no it's pretty bad in it for the
most part you can tell he's trying to
play this multi-dimensional character
that the audience isn't supposed to be
able to read but he just comes off as
too boring for us to be invested in
where's that body
don't fucking scream at me where's your
dummy fuck you look at you with your
fucking 48 percent body fat and you
around a little bastard fuck you guys he
does have a few moments in there but
overall it's definitely one of his more
subpar performances give me the weapon I
don't trust you David Ayer also directed
this movie about a team of rogues sound
familiar
nope number 3 Adam Gibson in the sixth
day who are you I am you then Who am I
yes
[Applause]
in the near future Adam Gibson comes
home one day to see a man who looks just
like him in his house with his family
soon mysterious agents like Michael
Rooker and Terry Crews are after him
apparently trying to kill him off Adam
then discovers a grand conspiracy that
involves illegal cloning and the madman
behind the practice well hey the XFL is
in this so apparently they got one thing
right about the future being 18 years
old we can start calling this one a
classic bad Arnold movie Arnold's
performance as Adam and Adams clone is
beyond ridiculous but it's played
straight for the most part why daddy I
said for the most part you have on
sports nigger playing opposite Arnold
Schwarzenegger the potential for
over-the-top fun is limitless what a
waste
number two ray Owens in the last stand
this was Arnold's big comeback movie
after taking ten years off of leading
films to serve as the Governor of
California and it shows a drug cartel
leader is speeding down to the border of
Arizona and Mexico in a state-of-the-art
sports car after the FBI fails to catch
up with him the only people left in his
way are an old sheriff and a small group
of untested deputies when Johnny
Knoxville is your comedic relief he
might not be in the most high quality
film Arnold is all kinds of rusty in
this movie he does have good later
performances like Maggie but he had to
shake off the cobwebs first and
sometimes that wasn't easy to watch
someone is to stay behind to keep the
peace consider yourself deputized okay
this just has direct-to-video written
all over it the only reason it got a
wide release was because of Arnold's
return and he didn't seem to get back in
the swing of things until a couple of
years later at least there's one thing
worse than this in his filmography
and the number one worst Arnold
Schwarzenegger performance is Howard
Langston in jingle all the way this was
tough to put on the list because it's my
favorite Christmas movie
wait why Oh Walter
really Howard Langston is a workaholic
family man who barely has time for his
young son Jamie when he realizes the one
thing Jamie wants for Christmas is the
hottest selling toy ever turbo man he
sets out on a Christmas Eve mission to
find one of these rare action figures
along the way high jinks ensue as
another dad in a similar situation
matches his desperation every turn
apparently Walter loves this movie so
much partially because of Arnold's awful
performance the film is both
intentionally and unintentionally
hilarious
Arnold trying to interact with young
Anakin is wow look so champ those hands
registers weapons yet it's obvious he
just didn't care too much the efforts
not really there we'd need a whole
episode just to talk about all that's
happening with this disaster piece just
know Arnold punches a reindeer and it's
the best and worst Christmas movie
moment ever you started it
a lot of these were newer films but keep
in mind most of Arnold's older bad
performances were meant to be cheesy in
his own signature way this was actually
harder to rank than you would believe we
want to hear what you guys think
what are your least favorite Arnold
Schwarzenegger movies and/or
performances what should we cover next
on the show leave a comment and let us
know to keep in touch you can find me on
Facebook as I own away tour everywhere
else as awesome Ayana and you can follow
me on twitter at Heather ruse Instagram
at H ruse or twitch twitch TV slash
Heather ruse we're gonna be looking for
Walter and we need your help use the
hashtag where's Walter and leave with
some theories where you think you might
have gone
I guess we'll see you next week on a new
top five bye
[Music]
so any ideas for next week yeah I think
I got some I'll talk to you tomorrow
sounds good see you then bye okay bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you